There's new fallout
tonight from that very disturbing
shooting involving
a six year old
who allegedly pulled the trigger
on his own teacher.
Brian Todd is working the story
Brian, give us the latest.
Wolf, the school board meeting
last night was packed beyond cap
with people filling overflow roo
Apparently, the opportunity
to channel anger
toward a school board
that is now under
enormous pressure was a hot tick
I send my kids to school and fin
praying to God
that they will return home safel
Emotional, furious parents
vent at school.
Officials in Newport News, Virgi
at the first school board meetin
since a six year
old boy shot
and wounded his first grade teac
in the classroom.
Don't want to have a family dinn
where I talk about
where my kids will hide in their
One woman said
her daughter was in the classroo
Neck Elementary School
when teacher Abby Zwirner was sh
She's six.
She's terrified
because the
person who was advocating for he
got hurt.
She got hurt.
She blamed school officials
for failing to prevent the shoot
Before the shooting,
a school employee had searched t
backpack based on a tip.
But found no gun.
You guys should have been defend
and protect her when she came
or whoever came
and said that there was a possib
in that
child's backpack or otherwise pa
expressing anger
that this was the third school
shooting in the Newport
News School District
since September of 20.
21 with one fatality,
one parent issuing a warning.
Enough is enough.
What will it take?
I pray it is not a fourth shooti
because that blood will be on yo
One parent said Trust in Newport
School officials
has been lost at all levels.
Parents and teachers
said in the Newport News Distric
many students who disrespect
teachers and engage in violence
no consequences.
And school officials
are accused of downplaying
or ignoring
disciplinary incidents
for favorable statistics.
Ask any teacher in this school d
why discipline incidents decline
And I have a feeling
the response will be the same.
Infraction numbers are down
because incidents are not always
officially reported.
Some at the meeting
called for Newport News School
Superintendent George Parker
and the entire school board to r
School officials say they're res
to the shooting
by installing metal detectors at
elementary schools in Newport Ne
And they're considering a rule
to require students
to bring only transparent backpa
to school.
One school security expert
calls that security theater.
The number one way
we find out about weapons in sch
is not from a metal detector,
but from a kid who comes forward
and tells an adult that they tru
It's about relationships.
We reached out to
the Newport
News School
District for a response to the a
that the district underreported
disciplinary incidents
and to ask
if Superintendent George Parker
or anyone on the school board
would resign. They didn't respon